l'arrivée du printemps est aussi
synonyme du retour de certains fruits et
légumes tels que les épinards les
carottes l'avocat ou encore le citron
pour les consommateurs qui arpentent les
allées du marché de maurepas c'est
important de consommer les produits de
saison
j'ai acheté des épinards du retiro du
show call j'adore ça c'est plein de
vitamine c est délicieux et qu'est-ce
que j'ai pris des autres une bonne
salade et les carottes les choix donc
c'est le maraîcher déjà pourquoi parce
que c'est une filière courte et
essentiellement du bio et après je suis
les saisons et lui aussi
grosso modo quoi un sondage ipsos
indique que 36 % des français
choisissent leurs fruits et légumes en
fonction de la saison
selon cette même étude il serait 56% à
faire confiance aux conseils de leurs
maraîchers selon leur menu des fois ils
nous demandent genre la pomme de terre
on a deux variétés de pommes de terre
neuve à la pomme de terre charlotte qui
est une pomme de terre assez ferme fait
plus pour faire sauter
à l'eau etc nous avons aussi la pomme de
terre mona lisa qui est plus une pomme
de terre qui se défait pour la purée l'a
soufflé foot
donc on fait faire les clients en
fonction de ce qu'ils veulent manger et
pour les gourmands sachez que la fraise
devrait faire son grand retour sur les
étals à partir du mois de mai et surtout
n'oubliez pas de manger cinq fruits et
légumes par jour